first of all congratulations on the show
it's so good you know within the first
five minutes
if you're like immediately hooked and
this show does that
um jesse let's start with you alina is
just someone who you just absolutely
fall in love with
um how great is it for you playing a
character who
learns to really embrace all her
strength and her power
yeah that's what i really love about
this part and about elena is that she
when we meet her she's not just a you
know a mary sue who's really strong
she starts off in a place where she is
super vulnerable and she's suspicious of
new people and
she doesn't know who she is and it was
really nice to be able to
show her growing throughout each episode
and you know she's got such a great
arc and a great journey and that was
really really exciting for me to play
and
go through all these different
iterations of this character she finds
out who she is
yeah it was really exciting well and
something else i just learned too so i
haven't read the books but
elena's backstory actually changed from
the books to now with the series so how
cool was that
really cool i think it was such a good
choice because
you know not only does her being mixed
race and being half
shoe um really add to the you know the
world building we we
understand that rafka is at war with
shuhan and so therefore alina is
told that she looks like the enemy her
whole life and that adds so much to you
know so many layers to her character
you know if you spend your whole life
being shunned and told you look like the
enemy that's gonna
shape who you are and i think elena's
strength
but that gentleness is a result of
having been
you know pushed aside the whole time and
she really wants to prove to everyone
that no i'm
i'm one of you and i'm i'm a ravican and
i'm proud of being ravka and i want to
help so
yeah it was a really lovely choice and
obviously i'm thrilled because i got to
play the part
yes you're so good in this part too
which is so much fun to watch
archie let's talk about the friendship
between mal
and alina um why is alina so important
to him and why is your connection so
strong through the whole series
um i think it's because of of just what
they've been through together
um even before the series starts they
they both lost their parents to the to
the shadow fold and they're grabbing
this orphanage together and crimson uh
where they're both seen as outsiders and
both kind of get bullied a little bit
and
elena looks after mao looks out for him
and and and then
as the story progresses the beginning of
the story uh of
of shannon buying the series uh and now
it's like kind of looking out for her
and making sure that she's all right
yeah and yeah it's just this this
incredibly strong bond that they have
because
of of this experience that they find
themselves in
i love it um ben let's talk about
general kira again so mysterious so
dark um obviously you're no stranger to
playing iconic rules this definitely
being
another one on your list um why is elena
so important to him because obviously
he's powerful all on his own
but how does um elena entering his life
change everything
i think what i love about fantasy is you
can be worlds away from your real
life and see people with powers that you
can only
imagine and on adventures that that you
can't really
fathom and yet you can feel yourselves
and see yourselves in these
in these characters and their struggles
and i think that um
you know there is balance in the light
versus the literal
darkness and um so to find someone
finally who has the opposite power to
his and to recognize something of
himself
um there's a moment where he's talking
to one of the other greisha in the story
where he says i know exactly how she
feels because it's exactly what i went
through i'm sure of it
and and and you understand that that she
is the into his yang in that way
but in that symbol there's a white dot
in the black half and a black dot in the
white half and
that became something that was kind of
um you know indicative to me
of of their relationship he sees
something of himself in her
and and i wanted to you know uh you know
the books obviously written in first
person but but
from alina's perspective but i wanted to
draw out his experience and his
humanity you know i'm drawn to
characters where you can look at
both both sides of somebody not just see
them on the surface but really see the
human being
underneath and and see how he's he's
drawn in by by her warmth and her
her sunlight well i just love you know
the development of all the characters i
mean honestly you really feel so
connected to them i love all the
supernatural elements to it
then how would you describe the fold why
is it so terrifying
well i think i think it's something that
has been looming um
for such a a long long time and kerrigan
obviously feels that the
the the heaviness and the pressure of it
bearing in mind that his four
ball bearers are blamed for its
existence
um and it obviously is a rip across them
across the
the the map of of of rabbka separating
into into two a bit like
the berlin wall or something but it also
i think kind of
it's filled with monsters and you know
these it represents people's demons and
you can't go around it you have to be
able to go through it if you want to
find
peace and so it's got a lovely symbolism
to it in that way as well
well congratulations on this show it's
um i i don't even think i was expecting
it to be so epic like it's really
beautifully done so congratulations
honestly i think people are going to
love it
thank you so much
you